You will recall, I hope, that
when discussing welfare theory
I identified five ways
in which a government can
seek to offset the under
production of public goods,
such as literature, art,
and scientific innovations.
To review, those five
strategies are-- first,
the government can provide
the public good itself,
as it does with respect to
navigation, AIDS, and space research.
Second, the government
can select and subsidize
private innovators, as it does with
respect to much research involving
health related sciences.
Third, the government can offer
prizes to successful innovators
an increasingly popular approach.
Fourth, the government can adopt laws
that reinforce innovator's self help
strategies, such laws include
protections for trade secrets,
and the kind of ant-circumvention
rules I mentioned a minute ago
and that we will examine
in more detail next week.
Fifth, and not least, the government can
protect producers against competition
in the reproduction, distribution,
and performance of their works.
As you know by now, copyright law
is an example of the fifth approach.
The topic for today is cultural
theory, not welfare theory,
but the same five options are
relevant when we cast about
for ways to advance the kinds of
society commended by cultural theory.
Some might be more efficacious than
reforming copyright law itself.
For example, if we believe that this
set of cultural products being produced
today is too thin to
sustain the kind of culture
and the set of opportunities
for artists that we want,
we could, as we've done in the
previous segment of this lecture,
tried to tune the copyright system.
Or instead, we could
supplement the incentives
created by copyright
protection with government
subsidies for the type of work at issue.
Several European countries already
do this with respect to cinema.
European national governments and
some regional governments offer
grants to filmmakers, typically new
filmmakers or filmmakers pursuing
unconventional projects, that
supplement the revenues they
can make by selling or
exhibiting copies of their films.
Where does the money come from?
Typically from taxes, either general
tax revenues or taxes on other forms
of entertainment.
The result is increased diversity
in the films available to consumers.
Whether the net result
is unbalance attractive
is perhaps a good test of
the merits of this approach.
An even more radical
possibility is the one
I considered briefly
in lecture number four.
If we despaired of relying
on the copyright system
to compensate fairly the creators
of musical compositions and films,
we might consider replacing
the copyright system altogether
with respect to online distribution
of sound recordings and films
with an alternative compensation system.
The gist of such a
system, you'll recall,
is that fees would be collected,
directly or indirectly, from businesses
that capitalize upon consumers
demand for digital recordings,
but currently pay nothing to the
creators of those recordings.
Such businesses include
internet service providers,
manufacturers of consumer
electronic equipment,
and media related application programs.
The funds collected in this manner would
then be distributed to the creators.
The formulas by which
they were distributed
would likely vary by country.
In the United States, where
suspicion of government is intense,
the money would likely be parceled out
among copyright owners in proportion
to the relative
popularity of their works.
In Europe as Philippe
Aigrain has argued,
relative popularity would likely
be alloyed with other criteria
when determining how
the money is divided.
Once such a system were in
place, online distribution
of movies and recorded
music would be legalized.
Viewed from the standpoint
of cultural theory,
such a system would have two main
advantages over our current regime.
First, it not only would
provide consumers lawful access
to many more cultural
products at low cost,
it would free them legally to modify
and redistribute those artifacts,
thus enhancing semiotic democracy.
No longer would YouTube's copyright
sniffing software suppress mash-ups
that happen to contain snippets
of other people's material.
Incidentally, YouTube's software
has balked at some of the lectures
in this series, forcing us to appeal
those rejections on the grounds
that the snippets that I employ
are shielded by fair use.
Whether such appeals, however well
founded, will continue to work
remains to be seen.
Back to main story.
Second, by enabling artists
to earn good incomes
by providing their works
directly to the public,
such an alternative compensation
system would sharply increase access
to the variant of the good life
associated with the creation of art.
As we've seen, an alternative
compensation system
would not be perfect.
Its disadvantages are cataloged on the
map, but it would have great strengths.
One of the most difficult issues
currently confronting lawmakers
throughout the world is
how, if at all, to shield
so-called "traditional knowledge"
against unauthorized uses.
Roughly speaking, the
term traditional knowledge
refers to cultural products
developed over long periods of time,
typically by the members
of indigenous groups.
Examples include traditional music,
dances, fabrics, costumes, folklore,
and religious icons.
Such things do not fit well
the template of copyright law.
In part because the
authors of such things
are usually collective, hard
to identify, and long dead.
In addition, the concerns
of the groups who
object to the non-permissive use of
traditional cultural expressions--
sometimes abbreviated
as TCEs-- are usually
quite different from the combination
of economic and personhood interests
implicated by most copyrighted works.
If copyright law doesn't work well in
this setting, what would work better?
That's far from clear.
Countries continue to experiment
with a wide variety of models.
Various insight into those possible ways
of dealing with traditional knowledge
might be derived from the cultural
theory we have outlined here.
Unfortunately, those insights conflict.
Cultural theory is thus
arguably helpful in identifying
some things we should strive
to achieve or protect,
but not particularly helpful
in telling us how to do so.
Here are some of the
competing considerations.
The use or performance or
TCEs is one of the ways
in which some communities
define and sustain themselves.
Because preservation
of communities is one
of the things commended
by cultural theory,
we should strive if possible
to protect these practices
from corrosion or dissipation.
Protecting TCEs from
appropriation by persons or firms
outside the indigenous groups
that created and sustained
them would also promote
cultural diversity
by helping to resist the trend towards
global cultural homogenization.
Allowing indigenous groups
to charge, or otherwise
be compensated for uses of their
TCEs, would also provide them
a source of funds that would
mitigate their impoverishment
and promote distributive justice.
Note however, that this
third consideration
is in some tension with
the first and second,
which seemed to presume that
the TCEs would not spread.
On the other side of the ledger,
protections for traditional knowledge
are hard to reconcile with the
value of semiotic democracy.
The merit of enabling all persons,
both members of an outsider's
to the indigenous groups, to refashion
cultural artifacts of all sorts.
Such protections are also hard to
reconcile with the value of autonomy,
of enabling all persons to choose
for themselves the cultural forms
through which they
will define themselves.
More broadly, the impulse to
protect TCEs against unauthorized
used or modification, seems rooted
in a static conception of identity
that diverges from the more
dynamic conception of identity
that figures in the conception
of the good life offered here.
So what's the right approach?
It's very hard to say.
That question seems best
left to the seminars that
will accompany this lecture series.
All copyright theories have
weaknesses, sore points.
The theory I've outlined today
is no exception in this regard.
Cultural theory has two main
weaknesses, both of which
are likely apparent by now.
The first is commonly referred
to as the perils of paternalism,
or as it's sometimes called parentalism.
Whichever term you prefer, it
means efforts by governments
to limit people's freedom or
otherwise channel their behavior, not
to protect the interests of
others, but for their own good.
Legal rules of this
sort are not unknown.
Familiar examples are rules requiring
motorcyclists to wear helmets,
rules forbidding people to sell
organs, bans on self enslavement,
prohibitions on the
use of certain drugs,
and the non-waivable
character of the implied
warranty of habitability
in landlord tenant law.
Nevertheless, such efforts are
hazardous and controversial.
The reason why the
specter of paternalism
arises in the present context is
that the vision of the good life,
upon which this variant of
cultural theory is founded,
does not align exactly with what most
people currently subjectively desire.
Thus to the extent the theory commends
modifications of copyright law
that will afford people more
access to a life of the sort,
and seeks to stimulate their
appreciation of such a life,
it does not defer entirely to people's
own assessment of their best interests.
But instead, pushes them in
directions they might not
be inclined to go for their own good.
Three factors mitigate the troubling
implications of that admission.
The first, is that the gap
between the vision outlined
in the first segment of this lecture
and people's subjective desires
is not as large as one might think.
The findings of the group
of scholars sometimes known
as the Princeton Group concerning
the ways in which people
assess their own well
being are reassuring.
In particular, the so-called
day reconstruction method,
pioneered by this group and applied
to the members of many classes
and to the residents of
many countries, reveals
that people take more pleasure
in some of the things commended
by the good life, such as
intimacy and friendship,
and less pleasure in consumption
and the trappings of status
than has traditionally been assumed.
Second, none of the
possible reforms I've
outlined force people to do anything.
You're not coercive.
Instead, they're designed
to alter incentives
in an effort to invite or nudge,
to use the term popularized
by Thaler and Sunstein,
people into better lives.
Third, it's not the case that
adoption of these proposals
would introduce paternalism into
copyright law for the first time.
As we've seen, extent
copyright law already
contains some even more
coercive rules that
constrain people's freedom
for their own good.
The clearest examples are the
non waivable termination rights
in sections 203 and
304 of the US statute,
which I discussed in lecture number six.
Why are those rights non waivable?
Because we wish to prevent artists
from signing away their entitlements
foolishly.
In other words, we disable
them from acting in ways
that we think are not in
their own best interests.
These three factors in combination
may assuage our unease somewhat,
but not entirely.
Two arguments against initiatives of
this general sort remain worrisome.
The first is the fundamental argument
made by liberal political theorist
and leaders, the government's
aught to remain neutral
concerning alternative
theories of the good.
The second, is a
prudential consideration.
Even if paternalistic rules are
not objectionable in principle,
it's foolhardy to entrust
government officials with the power
to override people's own
conceptions of their best interests.
This brings us to the second of the two
major sore points and cultural theory.
It would increase the degree to
which the shape of our culture
is determined by government officials.
The risks associated with
that strategy are familiar.
Bureaucrats are not famous for wisdom.
The persons and firms
who stand to gain or lose
from the decisions of the bureaucrats
would dissipate scarce social assets,
trying to persuade those bureaucrats
to take one tack or another.
In the worst case scenario,
the official's decisions
might be corrupt, either in the
strong sense of being purchased
by the affected parties, or the softer
sense of being motivated by a desire
to please the parties upon whose favor,
and donations, the officials depend.
These risks can be reduced by carefully
selecting the officials in whose hands
power is placed or by instituting
checks on their authority,
but they cannot be
eliminated altogether.
Whether they are fatal to this
enterprise, I leave to you.